i
galera de parauapebas amanhã sexta-feira
dia 20 de maio até o show aí em cores e
ingresso na óptica do povo rua marabá
número 94 centro é de marabá sábado dia
28 o show ingresso na tim do shopping
pátio marabá segundo piso galera de
tucuruí e dia 22 de maio domingo é ter
um show aí ingressos na ellus jeans no
tucuruvi shopping 1º piso na minha
família todo o show é bacana demais é aí
galera seu canal vocês vão até um canal
muito grande na internet é na internet a
retalho com quase oito milhões e meio de
pessoas
o pessoal sempre falou em buscar você é
um grande influenciador você tem que
mostrar os jovens em quem votar tem que
mostrar os jovens e que forma os jovens
não porque o jovem como se já fosse
mongolóide assim nenhum eu sempre ouvi
falar e discutir política porque eu não
entendo de política eu vou falar sobre
uma coisa que não tenho propriedade eu
não entendo nada vou assistir o acordo é
na televisão fazer sentar no banco vou
assistir a dilma falando se é fé e
gastón brasil estamos num momento que se
é ferro shan pra questão le petit à
petit polares café neckel o café um
chocolate o chocolate é importado a
gente o brasil no que se refere à
questão a família brasileira crescer da
união borboletinha tá na cozinha trazer
trazendo o que chocolate chocolate
aí o choco aí já atraiu jataí no que se
referem em questão de chocolate temos
muito na música orban o brasil é um
grande exportador de chocolate aí é que
eu não entendo por nenhuma ninguém
entende porque você não sabe se a dilma
só o pedro bial que está falando não ver
ou não ver marina silva mas então desce
dentro estamos tentado mudar o brasil eu
já teve dengue malária
a febre amarela malária dengue malária
três vezes
tivemos muita febre e iremos malária ao
cubo a votação olímpica em gel e
cuspindo bolsonaro bolsonaro a nenê
levou já o irã acha engraçado é que
sempre tem algum filme pode estar
pensando acho que os outros ministros
senadores já vou pra cama já
proporcionava pagando as coisas que vou
apagar tudo aqui ou liberar espaço que
vai da américa o flu mais apoio vovó a
idéia é ter sucesso é bota atenção
sempre que acontece uma merda é um
filmão é que essa política totalmente
fora da política do interior e eu vivia
polícia no interior política no interior
e fred me política no interior é assim
eu não voto em você minha paulo eu não
voto em você que gosta de você na sua
família seu paulo kung pisa que na minha
casa de novo vai silva time do milheiro
de telha frente meu patrão e acham que a
equipe esqueça do mundo vou deixar aqui
em casa amanhã de tarde não voltar aqui
na boa tamanho o menino notar que eles
recebem pra mim é e ganhou o voto
convenceu nem menina bicho beijo crédito
quando era criança a gente brincava de
colecionar os antigos cara tinha que ver
quem tinha mais antigo que o que valeu
avalia se o cara vereador deputado
presidiu por exemplo que ela tivesse 27
do lula que o presidente tivesse quatro
santini senador que ganhar para sátiro
que era o maior é o patrão se para fazer
os come só dava menino só dava criança
ontem ele fez um comício para duas mil
pessoas 1.800 menina vai passar os
carros de som jogando santinhos joga na
bola do paraíba e um minutos embaixo há
um ano atrás paródia o que pode faltar
político do interior é as paródia da
música pegava o chocolate é do ronaldo
por banda o isco água de coco pra mim
tanto faz a fazer
josé joaquim é um homem do povo ele é
demais ele fez muitas estradas e ainda
quer fazer mãe
é votar nele que vem mann
é para e volta agora nas seila socorro
do povo um defeito em um candidato assim
a socorro do povo tem o que eu sempre
achei muito engraçado eu não sei de onde
colocar a criança que o lobão tem um
papel desse ano politicamente graçado se
eu fosse político é criar um projeto de
lei para ser preso jeito que come pizza
de garfar jeito que coloque o arroz por
cima do feijão e gente que fala sap sap
tem ódio é um juízo e bloqueou a tap tem
quase certeza que é porque alguém chegou
perto deles esse rapaz ter parceiros
apesar de falar o que eu já fiz até
passei a não tem os acusados marlon que
essa [ __ ] whatsapp gente fala fala fala
o app store o aplicativo de mandar
mensagens instantâneas a pedir uma
opinião cada um é um exercício cidadão
cartão e vai lá votar nessa tecla
contigo seu futuro do país está nas suas
mãos
eu não gosto muito voltar e te pegar
fila e eu odeio fila porque fila me
lembro aquele momento estava na rede de
supermercado com a minha mãe era cardeal
fica que guardar lugar na fila eu vou
buscar farinha e eu já vou só que essa
falha para ficar foi plantar mandioca
descascar a moeda está no forno peneirar
eu olhando pra trás e nada da minha mãe
que o pessoal da fila andando é a fila
andou na fila andando e eu chegando
perto e um carrinho de compra lo tábuas
que não chega a minha vez de moça é
porque minha mãe primeiro encontro não
faria a série vai passando aí tem que
observar como é que ela chega ea moça
passa e me olhando
mãe é mãe mãe chegar ao alto e partito
'meu anos por pagá lo e nem importa
mesmo que ela não sai para buscar
farinha mesmo que seja só uma ou pagar
uma coisa normal minha mãe tem um
negócio é o seguinte é toda vez que está
na fila ela faz amizade com a fila toda
o filho devagar na mulher realmente quer
bem rapidinho ela trabalha na creche
nela fica conversando e eu fico aqui na
merda e minha mãe fila é o seguinte se
ela não faz amizade da fila encontra uma
amizade da fila é aquela marca de se
encontrar lá a mulher passa lá em casa
hoje sou mulher não dá não tem que fazer
compra mulher também vou fazer compras e
fechou hoje se encontra na noite de
ontem confiante que a compra consciente
não é só na fila do caixa
o texto quando alguns encontros milhões
de seguidores mas eu não sei desse
assunto para falar você então o que eu
vou falar vocês é o seguinte a base
política não vale da telha não lhe dá
bom não é pagar passagem pra você voltar
para sua casa não é prometer reforma da
sua casa o lyon tem que prometer nada
pra você e ele não tem que prometer nada
pra ninguém ele tem de fazer e ele tem
que fazer pelo povo não só com você
então quando você for votar a extensão
presidente você gostou de se ver você já
sabe só clique gostei aqui embaixo no
youtube volta lá no facebook onde eu
postei vídeo novo seu tempo político
você clica lá encurte e marca seus
amigos que também não entende de
política como eu ou que entende que eu
achar esse vídeo engraçado marquei lá
não se esquece de curtir no facebook
esse vídeo é muito importante o link
aqui embaixo vocês também é muito
importante pra mim que escreve o canal
para acompanhar todos os reinos
dependendo o vídeo me segue nas redes
sociais aqui é valeu é nóis beijam